so you get out and then is it like from
there you're like I need to try to chase
this rap Dream well I got out and then
um
I started rapping a little bit and then
you know honestly I got back into
trapping a lot and then um
me and NADA NADA had actually made a bet
with me because you know I had like that
dibbled and dabbled he was like man if I
get a Lamborghini you know
um you got to make a mixtape that's what
we bet you know what I'm saying so he
ended up getting a Lambo that's how I
made my first mixtape what year was that
and then 2000
14.
[__] okay yeah maybe because because
that first you know my first mixtape got
landed in hands of Ross
and then like that was like kind of a
jump that's how you kind of started to
link up with Ross because at the time
Ross is in Vegas all the time he was
he's with you guys all the time that's
when me was first coming out and
everything so yeah
um around 2014 yeah and like I said the
first mixtape I dropped got me got in
his hands crazy so from there like
because are you technically signed to
MMG because so it's a management yeah
I'm not I'm not signing to the label as
an artist but I'm signed into their
management yeah like what was it about
because I do feel like Ross has always
had a great year for picking Talent we
think of Meek Mill Wale pill uh I mean
we go on and on and on but what was it
about like your guys's relationship or
well
Ross had seen um
I was financially stable
right so he was like man don't sign to a
label
you know do your independent thing and
when the labels come in I'll come in
there and we'll negotiate everything so
they know they can't play with you and
we're gonna get you what you need to do
right so run with the brand and
and then when it's time to do major
deals you know he's involved you know
what I'm saying so that was kind of the
arrangement on that wow damn 2014 that's
like
almost 10 years ago yeah eight years ago
yeah
damn yeah I'd already I'd already moved
out of Vegas at that time it's been a
long grind man I think that first year I
even started [__] with Ross I dropped
like six mixtapes yeah you reside you
would definitely turn it up